everyone has a weak spot and there's
bound to be a film out there that pushes
one or two of your buttons these movies
on the other hand push all of them they
aren't just hard to watch they're deeply
disturbing on almost every level and
some of them are downright vile in fact
many people couldn't even finish them
and for good reason
hold on because these are some of the
most disturbing movies ever made
Veronica Netflix's quick ascent to the
top of the entertainment industry goes
hand-in-hand with the rise of binge
watching in fact the company seems
dedicated to trying its best to make
sure that you never ever turn off your
television that's what makes Veronica so
surprising in March 2018 this
spanish-language horror film made
headlines because people were so scared
that they couldn't make it through the
entire thing and Netflix couldn't be
happier
plot-wise Veronica doesn't break any new
ground the title character misses her
deceased father and her friend wants to
talk to a deceased boyfriend and so the
girls use a Ouija board and a solar
eclipse to summon their spirits as tends
to happen when we chew boards are
involved things don't go according to
plan you know what to expect or at least
you think you do Veronica succeeds where
other films fall short through a mixture
of real-life terror and pitch perfect
filmmaking it knows how to push all the
right buttons and that elevates a
standard horror flick to what some
people are calling the scariest movie
ever
after watching Veronica some viewers are
plagued by nightmares for days others
can only go to sleep with the lights on
after watching
and those are just the people who
finished the movie many don't make it
that far
life is short after all why spend the
rest of it cowering in fear teeth of
course Veronica isn't the only
disturbing movie on Netflix that people
keep bailing on in Veronica's aftermath
the streaming service reached out to
Forbes and provided a list of ten movies
that are so scary people just won't
watch them until the end many of the
entries on the list makes sense The
Human Centipede too full sequence so
gross that it was banned in Britain and
in Australia and if the violence in
2016's cabin fever doesn't get you the
rest of the production probably will it
has a shockingly low rating on Rotten
Tomatoes and yet even among these
shockers teeth stands out in the film
the main character is Don O'Keeffe a
Christian abstinence advocate who
suffers from a condition that or to put
it as mildly as possible has teeth where
she shouldn't have teeth as such many of
teeth scenes aren't just uncomfortable
they're intentionally squirming inducing
especially for the guys in the audience
it's no wonder so few viewers last until
the credits roll mother Darren
Aronofsky's mother isn't a traditional
horror movie it doesn't have any
monsters or supernatural threats but
that doesn't make the film any less
troubling love it or hate it mother is
successfully disturbing thanks largely
to the brutal and relentless abuse
heaped on Jennifer Lawrence's character
taking altogether it's kind of a lot too
much in fact some critics found mothers
graphic depictions supremely distasteful
audiences agreed people flock to the
exits during Mother's theatrical
screenings and we can't say we blame
them raw maybe you didn't complete a
film because you decided to turn it off
maybe you're simply too grossed out to
stay in the theatre sometimes however
you don't have a choice people didn't
just walk out of raw they found the
movie so disturbing that they passed out
in the theater try finishing a movie
while you're unconscious as far as raw
is concerned
it only takes a single scene to get
everyone's stomachs heavey when raw
begins veterinary student Justine is a
lifelong vegetarian but she's forced to
consume meat as part of a hazing ritual
as a result she's consumed by a very
specific
cific hunger a hamburger doesn't do the
trick neither does raw chicken it's only
after Justine's sister accidentally cuts
off her own finger and passes out that
Justine finds the answer
Justine picks up the severed appendage
and well you get the idea for a couple
of viewers at the Toronto International
Film Festival that was enough at least
two people passed out forcing the
festival to call an ambulance
others fled to prevent vomiting and
that's just the beginning - Justine's
cravings don't end with just a finger
and it's probably best for everyone that
the more sensitive members of the
audience didn't stick around to see just
how depraved things get a Serbian film
even if you've got an unnaturally high
tolerance for grotesque scenes in movies
you've probably got some kind of limit
chances are a Serbian film will find it
and then blow right past it
of course the Serbian film isn't just
shocking for shocks sake it's got social
and political messages that's what the
director says anyway he told electric
sheet magazine it's a struggle against
all the corrupt authorities that govern
our lives for their own purposes
when it comes to Serbia specifically the
director said the movie represents a
metaphor for the monolithic power of
leaders who hypnotized you to do things
you don't want to do whether it's
successful is up for debate what we do
know is that a serbian film is intensely
disturbing even some employees at the
distribution company responsible for its
US release couldn't finish it
unless you're desensitized to well
everything there's no reason to think
that you'll do any better
Caligula according to legend the Roman
Emperor Caligula wasn't a nice guy and
the movie Caligula is as depraved as its
subject matter there's also just way too
much of it with a runtime that borders
on three hours Caligula requires a major
time investment and all of that
debauchery gets exhausting fast even
acclaimed film critic Roger Ebert
couldn't sit through it sane disgusted
and unspeakably depressed I walked out
of the film after two hours of its 170
minute length the great ecstasy of
Robert Carmichael you could watch the
great ecstasy of Robert Carmichael all
the way through but why by all accounts
the film is thoroughly unpleasant
according to Variety a few of its scenes
quote make a Clockwork Orange look like
a Britney Spears video when the film
screened it can one scene prompted a
mass walkout
given that one critic called the great
ecstasy of Robert Carmichael's climax a
sequence excruciating beyond any and
memory we're gonna bet that the can
showing wasn't the only time everyone
bailed not that the rest of the great
ecstasy of Robert Carmichael is
particularly easy to watch of course by
the time Robert becomes an ecstasy
dealer he's more or less beyond
redemption and the audience is more or
less done with it all
hereditary in hereditary toni collette
plays an artist annie who just lost her
borderline abusive mother to cancer
meanwhile her relationships with her
husband her son and her daughter are
slowly deteriorating that's enough to
make hereditary uncomfortable from the
start when the scares start dropping it
becomes unbearable
writer-director Ari Astor describes his
critically acclaimed haunted house film
as a personal project saying I had gone
through some stuff with my family
I took my sickness and now put it inside
all of you Astor didn't elaborate
further but whatever the issue was it
must have been messed up hereditary
isn't just the strongest debut from a
horror director since get out it's one
of the most terrifying films to come
along in years if you can manage to sit
through the whole thing
not everyone can while hereditary
received rave reviews when it's screened
at Sundance
it was also scary enough to drive many
viewers from the theater even people who
stayed for the whole thing didn't really
want to by all accounts the film isn't
unsettling because of its jump scares
it's hard to watch because the
characters pain is so real meet the
Feebles if you're bored try this invite
some friends over make sure they're
relaxed and then put on meet the Feebles
don't tell them what's coming don't
reveal that what starts as a low-budget
Muppet knockoff quickly transforms into
something much much worse let your
buddies discover that for themselves and
see how long it takes before you don't
have any friends left anyone who grew up
with the Muppets will either find meet
the Feebles darkly hilarious or deeply
disturbing watching off-brand versions
of Jim Henson's classic characters
dropped into the seedy underbelly of a
crime-ridden City is nearly unbearable
oh and did we mention that meet the
Feebles was directed by Peter Jackson
the man who brought middle-earth to the
big screen yep that's right at some
point someone saw meet the Feebles and
thought Peter Jackson should be given
nearly 300 million dollars in the
freedom to make a few of the most
ambitious films of all time
sure meet the Feebles may be too
disturbing for many viewers to finish
but for Peter Jackson
worked out very well indeed
[Music]